[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشرات الرابعه من
الرياض
على محافظه جده خلال 6 ساعات
الارصاد تصدر تحذيرا لهطول امطار غزيره
على السواحل الغربيه وتحذر من السيول
المنقوله
الصادرات غير النفطيه السعوديه تسجل
ارتفاعا باكثر من 13% خلال 3 اشهر
رابعه كذلك
سويسرا تتغلب على الكاميرون والبرازيل
تواجه صربيا مساء اليوم في اولى مبارياتها
الموارد البشريه السعوديه توقف اربعه
شركات استقدام بسبب مخالفتها الانظمه
واللوائح
حياكم الله اعلن المركز الوطني للارصاد في
السعوديه عن اعلى كميه امطار على مدينه
جده وذلك من الثامنه صباحا وحتى الثانيه
من بعد ظهر اليوم والتي بلغت وتسعه 179
ملم المركز اوضح من خلال التقرير الذي
اصدره ان كميه الامطار التي هطلت اليوم
على جده تتجاوز كميه الامطار المسجله في
عام 2009
[موسيقى]
مجد المتحدث باسم المركز الوطني للارصاد
حسين القحطاني سيد حسين مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض بدايه هل كنتم على
علم او توقع مؤكد هطول هذه الكميه الكبيره
من الامطار على محافظه جده
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم حقيقه تقارير
المركز الوطني للارصاد اشارت منذ وقت مبكر
الى
حاله غزيره الى شديده الغزال
مقوله تشمل معظم مناطق المملكه
واشارت بشكل واضح الى منطقه مكه المكرمه
وسواحلها تشمل محافظه جده التي سجلت اليوم
امطار غزيره
يعني متاخره من قبل قليل يعني وما زالت
الفرصه ايضا مهيئه
الامطار على جده اليوم هي اعلى من كميات
الامطار التي هطلت على اداه المدينه في
عام 2009 ونهايه 2008
نعم حقيقه هذه اعلى كميه امطار سجلت حتى
الان على جده ب 179 مللي في المناطق
الجنوبيه ولكنها تفاوتت في مناطق
الشماليه الجنه في مصر مطار الملك عبد
العزيز حوالي 83 الى 84 ملي متر لكن اعلى
كميه امطار كانت في المناطق الجنوبيه
لمحافظه جده وبلاغه تجاوزت ال 179 مليون
وهي اعلى كميه امطار مسجله همم مقارنه
بالامطار التي سجلناها في 2009 و20 2011
منذ متى بدا التنسيق مع الجهات المعنيه في
همم جده سواء مع ال- ال- المحافظه طبعا
اتحدث عن الامانه الدفاع المدني وغيرها من
الجهات المعنيه منذ اي وقت قبل هطول هذه
الامطار
نعم بلا شك هناك اليه متبعه مع الجهاز ذات
العلاقه التي تتعامل ميدانيه مع الظواهر
الجويه هذه الاهليه لديها اطار زمني واطار
معلوماتي ويتم التنسيق من خلالها منذ وقت
مبكرا حتى تقوم هذه الجهات باتحاد
الاجراءات الميدانيه وخطوطها المناسبه للت
عامل
وقت مبكر
الى متى ستستمر هذه الحاله حسب
التقديراتكم في المركز الوطني
نعم حقيقه ما زال المركز الوطني للارصاد
يشير الى ان الفرصه ما زالت معيا والحاله
الحاله المطريه قد تكون تستمر معنا حتى
يوم الغد ولكنها قد تتفاوت عما كانت عليه
اليوم
ستتكرر في مدن ومحافظات اخرى في السعوديه
خلال الايام القادمه
[موسيقى]
ان محافظه جده كميه الامطار التي هطلت
عليها اليوم كانت عاليه والمتوقع ان
الساعات القادمه او حتى يوم الغد هناك
فرصه مهمه ولكنها لن تكون بنفس المعدلات
التي هطلت
اه يعني ستختلف ستقل هذه
الكميه من الامطار يعني حسب التوقعات لن
تواجه جدا يعني هذا السيناريو 179 ملم
اللي كان طبعا حسب التقديرات هو الاعلى من
دول 2009 تقريبا
24 ساعه من المركز الوطني لتقديم كل
الاحتمالات التي يمكن ان تكون على هذه
الظاهره على محافظه جده اول المناطق طبعا
يعني بالصور والفيديوهات اللي احنا
تابعناها اكثر المناطق اللي لها الامطار
وتركزت فيها الامطار والسحب والركاميه هي
جنوب شرق جده ليس كذلك سيد حسين
يا عم ايضا شمال جده يعني كميه الامطار في
الشمال جده سجلنا اعلى من 84% وهي ايضا
معدلات ليست بسيطه يعني لانه اول مره تسجل
في الحاله ايضا معدلات عاليه يعني تمام 83
في فتره زمنيه يعني سجلنا في الساعات
الاولى ما بين الساعه 8:00 الى الساعه
الى صباح
نا مرصد مطار الملك عبد العزيز كان 60 ملي
ثم ارتفعت عليه كميه الامطار مع بعد ذلك
بالنسبه للمطار جده هسه تؤثر هذه الحاله
على حركه همم الملاحه الجويه خلال الساعات
ال- همم القادمه
حقيقه المركز الوطني للارصاد معني بتقديم
هذه المعلومات ومستوى الحاله وشدتها
والجهات المعنيه في المصادر اتخذ
الاجراءات المعنيه بذلك هل ازاله الحاله
حاله انذار مبكر او اصبحت انذار متقدم
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من جدا ومتحدث باسم
المركز الوطني للارصاد حسين القحطاني
متحدث باسم امانه محافظه جده محمد البقمي
سيد محمد مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره بعد
هذه الصوره التي تكررت وتتكرر دائما مع كل
همم موسم ابطال غزيره او حتى متوسطه في
جده يعني شاهدنا غرق الشوارع الرئيسيه
واغلاق عدد من الشوارع المهمه الكباري
الانفاق الاحياء التي همم غرقت سيارات
التي يعني تراكمت في هذه الاحياء وكاننا
مره اخرى نعود الى نفسي ناريو 2009 ما
الذي حدث
الذي حدث في 2009 كان مستوى الامطار 2011
70 مل الى 111 مل
الامطار اللي تعرضت لها مدينه جده جده هذا
اليوم همم بلغت كميه الامطار نحو 180 مللي
واستمرت لنحو 8 ساعات متواصله لكن بفضل
الله ثم بفضل الانشاء السدود 15 سنه
شرق المدينه ساهمت في تخفيف الاضرار
والحمد لله قبل الحديث
عن المشاريع التي كانت همم خططتم لها ايضا
اعلنتم ايضا عن تنفيذ بعضها منذ 2000 2019
تحدث عن مشاريع تصريف الامطار تجمعات
المياه ايضا ما الذي حدث فيها هل تمت هذه
المشاريع هل توقفت لان الصوره التي
نشاهدها تقول بان المشكله تتكرر مره اخرى
حقيقه مثل ما ذكرت لك يعني لو قارن بين
حجم وكميه المياه التي هطلت الان او اليوم
وكميه المياه التي هطلت السابق اليها
ثلاثه اضعاف يمكن في 2009 لكن الحمد لله
المشاهد اللي في 2009 والكارثه اللي حصلت
2009 لم تتكرر
في ما يخص المشاري
انا يعني كارثه ال- ال- اللي حدث في
الاحياء في الطرق الرئيسيه في اغلاقها في
جنوب جده في شرق جده قبل قليل ايضا حتى
يتحدث المتحدث الرسمي بانها ايضا حتى في
شمال جده كميه الامطار فيها عاليه
وبالتالي صار في اغلاق طرق في في في شمال
جده وبعض الاحياء المهمه ايضا
يعني حول حوالي 180
مبلغ يعني كميه كبيره همم
[موسيقى]
لحظنا ان سدود ساهمت بشكل كبير
جدا
واحياء ايضا غمره
مثل ما انا اعرف شبكه المياه الامطار في
المدينه لا تتجاوز 20% من
اغطيات هذه المدينه طبعا هناك مشاريع
لزياده همم تغطيه المدينه تم الانتهاء من
10 مشاريع
مشاري سيدنا محمد
موجوده واعلنا عنها في موقع الامانه في
جميع وسائل الاعلام من ضمنها العربيه
نشرتها هذه المشاريع في البنوك يعني وين
تركزت هذه المشاريع
اماكن ذات الاولويه ولا ما اقصر الحرجه
اللي تكثر فيها التجمعات المياه وتتكرر
فيها تجمعات المياه
جدا واكثر مناطق اللي تعرضت اليوم
التجمعات المياه الامطار الشوارع اللي
غرقت فيها الاحياء ايضا كذلك اغلاق
السيارات والانفاقه غير كانت في جده
طبعا المشاريع لم تكتمل حتى الان ااا في
مشاريع جاري تنفيذها اما في ما يخص
المناطق التي لا يوجد فيها شبكه تصريح
بالمياه الامطار وضعت الامانه خطه بان
خلال 16 بلديه فرعيه تم توزيع اكثر من
2500عامل وموظف
960 اليه ومعده
الهدف من هذه انه سحب المياه وتسهيل حركه
التنقل داخل المدينه الاعمال مستمره لرفع
اضرار المياه
اكيد انتم من احد واهم هذه الجهاد بهذه
الحاله منذ وقت مبكرا اتحدث هنا عن الخطه
التي وضعتها للتعامل مع بهذا الموسم
الامطار والقطه اللي بتتعاملوا معها مع
اليوم ايضا متى بدات كانت بوصله ايضا حتى
منها
تم نشر لجميع الفرق على المواقع في نطاق
16 بلديه فرعيه
بشرت الفرق اعمالها جاري سحب المياه ورفع
الانقاض الناتجه عن الحاله المطريه
والاعمال المستمره ان شاء الله
مناطق في الجنوب وفي شرق جده ايضا وقلتوا
انها مناطق جريان سيول ايضا وكان فيها
مناطق ايقاف اعطاء رخص البناء وغيره
وصار عليها المناطق
مثل ما ذكرته التي تم تنفيذ 15 سد هذه
السدود ساهمت في منع المياه المنقوله ان
تصل الى المدينه والحمد لله مثل ما ذكرت
لك يعني نسبه المياه وكميه المياه الكبيره
لم تلحق الضرر الذي حدث في عام 2009 او
الذي حدث في عام 2011
اعطاء الرخص فيها بازلت فيها الاحياء اللي
موجوده
في الشرق
ولم تعطوا فيها رخص لم تعد الرخص لها مره
اخرى
طيب انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات المتحدث باسم امانه محافظه جده
السيد محمد البقمي في جده اتحول الى سلطان
السلم بمراسل العربيه السلطان مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض تتواجد في
شرق جده كيف تصف صوره ومشهد جدا منذ صباح
حتى الان سلطان
اهلا بك نايف واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل منذ ساعات الصباح لولو
احنا نتجول داخل الاحياء وسط وشرق وجنوب
امام محافظه جده كميه كبيره من المياه
الخاصه بالامطار وجريان السيول المنقوله
وخصوصا في مناطق شرق جدا اتحدثون عن حي
الحرازات وكذلك حي الصواعد وايضا اجزاء
كبيره من حي ابراج الرغامه فيما يتعلق في
منطقه الجنوبيه نتحدث على الاسكان وكذلك
حي السنابل والمناطق الاخرى مثل منطقه
الخمره وحي الفضيله وغيرها من الاحياء
الجنوبيه التي تضررت بشكل مباشر جدا
شاهدنا ورصدنا عدد كبير من المكارات التي
يعني اصبحت تالفه بشكل كبير جراء جريان
المياه لها ايضا تحدث على بعض عدد كبير من
المنازل التي تضررت بشكل مباشر من خلال
دخول المياه الى الاحوشه الخاصه بها وكذلك
دخول المياه عبر الاسقف الخاصه بالمنازل
ان هيك كان حالات الاحتجاز العديده التي
بشرتها فرق الدفاع المدني وك كحالات الماس
الكهربائي التي عملت عليها فرقه الدفاع
المدني وكذلك الشركه السعوديه للكهرباء في
الناحيه الاخرى انتقلنا في وسط جده تحدث
على شارقه على خط الحرمين الشريان الرئيس
الذي يربط بين شمال وجنوب جدا تم اغلاقه
بالكامل في تمام الساعه 9:00 صباحا نتحدث
على مناطق اخرى مثل الخط الذي يربط بين
مكه وجده والخط السريع تم اغلاقه بالكامل
جراء جريان البياه الكبير في هذه المناطق
ايضا فيما يتعلق بالخطوط الرئيسيه التي
تربط بين الشرق وغرب همم جده نتحدث على
نفقه شارع الستين والسبعين وكذلك شارع
صاري وبعض الميادين الكبرى هذه الميادين
اغلقت بالكامل جرائم امتلائها بالمياه
تعمل فرقه همم الامانه والدفاع المدني في
هذه المواقع بشكل همم كم مكثف وكبير جدا
لشفط المياه ايضا الهلال الاحمر السعودي
بشر همم بشكل كبير جدا حالات احتجاج تم
همم مباشره وكذلك كانت عندها مركز
العمليات التي يستقبل بشكل متواصل
البلاغات من قبل المواطنين والمقيمين
اتواجد حاليا في حي النخيل هذا الحي الذي
وهو يعتبر من مناطق الشرق جده نتحدث على
مجرى رئيسي يقع بالقرب من هذه المنطقه وهو
ممتلئ بالكامل بالمياه نتحدث على اضرار
كبيره لحقت بالبيوت والمنازل وايضا
المركبات الخاصه في المواقفه في اراضي
وحتى المواقف الجانبيه الخاصه بالاحياء
السكنيه الكل من السكان والمقيمين اليوم
كان يعيش حاله دعر كبيره اتجاه هذه المياه
او التي وصلت نسبتها الى 179 مل هذا رقم
كبير جدا اليوم شاهدنا في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وكذلك من خلال رصدنا الميداني
حالات احتجاج كبيره انقطاع الكهرباء في
عدد كبير من احياء جنوب وشرق محافظه جده
الاسيه من هذه المناطق ليست مزوده في
شبكات تصريف المياه او مغطاه يا سلطان انت
من تواجدك في هذه المناطق ما الذي تغير في
شبكات تصريف المياه يعني قبل قليل المتحدث
باسم الامانه يقول بان هناك مشاريع نفذت
مشاريع تم الانتهاء منها ومشاريع لازال
العمل عليها لا حتى هذه اللحظه حيث انت
وحيث رصت هل تغير شيء في هذه المشاريع هل
هي ملموسه امامك
الصوره الصوره زميلي نايف ابلغ من الكلام
اليوم لما نشاهد يعني تصاريحها وبيانات
صحفيه تؤكد وجود مشاريع تصاريح تصريف
للمياه ولكن الواقع مختلف والصوره مختلفه
من خلال مشاهدات ومرصدته الكاميرا العربيه
ولا اللقطات التي انتشرت في كافه مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي من خلال امتلاء هذه
الانفاق بشكل كبير جدا بالمياه وتم
اغلاقها ووجود كذلك اليات الشطه الخاصه
بامانه جده وفره الدفاع المدني التي تعمل
بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه اليوم مشاريع
تصريف المياه الامطار التي موجوده في
انفاق محافظه جده لا تستطيع استيعاب اكثر
من 60 ملي متر لذلك المياه التي وجدت
اليوم او انهالت على جده هذه الامطار منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى لا تستطيع هذه
المشاريع استيعاب اليوم 179 مللي رقم كبير
جدا المفترض انه يكون تعال مع مثل حالات
هذه من سنوات طويله جدا شهد جدا همم بعض
هذه مثل هذه الكوارث من خلال الكبيره لكن
اليوم شرايين جدا الرئيسيه هي مشلوله
بالكامل حتى هذه الساعه نعم
شكرا جزيلا لكم بالسلامه ان شاء الله من
شاركوا جدا مراسل العربيه سلطان السلومي
شكرا جزيلا لك
رابع مستمر وفي بعد قليل ايضا
ولي العهد السعودي يعلن عن اعتماد التوجه
التنموي حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت وزاره
سياحه العمانيه عن وصول السياح الى نحو
عشره الاف زائر حتى شهر سبتمبر الماضي من
هذا العام والجانب الاخر وقعت وزاره
التراث والسياحه عقود الانتفاع للتعزيز
الاستثمار في القطاع السياحي العماني
مواكبه للتوجهات الاقتصاديه لرؤيه 20 40
في استقطاب استثمارات تبلغ ثلاثه مليارات
ريال
مسقط ينضم الينا منفد العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض عبد الرحمن
اريد الحديث عن انقطاع همم السياحي في
عمان بعد الجائحه وايضا حتى تاثيرات
الازمات في العالم وبالاخصص مثل الازمه
الاوكرانيه الروسيه كيف يبدو هذا القطاع
هل تعافى ما هي الحاله التي يعيشها الان
نعم هناك تعافي كبير نايف في القطاع
السياحي والاقتصادي هنا في سلطنه عمان
تصحيح للرقم نايف هناك حوالي 100,000 زائر
حتى شهر سبتمبر الماضي قبل شهرين وصلوا
الى سلطنه عمان وزارو ابرز المواقع
السياحيه في تسعه اشهر 100,000 زائر عدد
كبير ومهم سادع زميلي وليد ياخذ لكم بعض
اللقطات نحن في احد المشاريع السياحيه
الموج مسقط هذا المشروع الرائد جدا والذي
يقدم جوده حياه عاليه في العاصمه العمانيه
او المارينا ايضا عدد من المطاعم والمواقع
السياحيه نايف اذا ما تحدثنا عن ابرز
الارقام حول المشاريع السياحيه هناك
انتعاش كبير ونمو بنسبه
23.1% خلال نصف الاول من عام 20 22 مقارنه
بنفس المده من العام الماضي والسلطنه تعمل
على تعزيز دور السياحه حوالي سبع مليارات
دولار تريد ان تجذبها الى القطاع السياحي
من ضمن مشاريع رؤيه 20 40 الخاصه
لسلطنه عمان اذا ما تحدثنا ايضا عن
المشاريع الاقتصاديه نايف الاسبوع الماضي
احتفلت السلطنه عمان باعيدها الوطني ومن
خلال هذا العيد تم الاعلان عن عدد من
المشاريع الرئيسيه اكثر من 10 مشاريع
وطنيه رائده متنوعه لكافه المحافظات
والولايات هنا في السلطنه همم السلطنه همم
عمان ستوفر اكثر من
680 فرصه عمل مباشره وغير مباشره ومن
المتوقع ان همم يرصد لهذه المشاريع العشره
حوالي 750 مليون ريال عماني اي تقريبا ما
يقارب اكثر من اثنين مليار ايه الدولار
يتم انجازها على
مدى السنوات القليله القادمه هناك حرس
كبير من السلطات العمانيه على اولا ايجاد
فرص عمل للشباب العماني من خلال هذه
المشاريع نسيمه القطاع السياحي الذي تضرر
كثيرا خلال السنتين الماضيتين الجراء
جائحه كورونا وايضا الازمات الموجوده في
المنطقه لكن الان كما نشاهد مع اجواء ايضا
كاس العالم نايف يعني المطاعم والمقاهي
وفرت الشاشات وفره الجلسات الجميله ايضا
لن ننسى ان الان الجو بدا بالاعتدال هنا
في سلطنه عمان وتحديدا في مسقط مع شهر
نوفمبر تبدا الاجواء الجميله ويبدا الهواء
العليل فنلاحظ اغلب الناس يحبون جسمهم في
الاماكن المفتوحه والخارجيه لتناول الطعام
وايضا الاستمتاع بالاجواء شبه الشتويه حتى
الان لم تصل الى درجه البروده العاليه لكن
هناك نتعاش ملحوظ وانتعاش كبير لم تزوجت
ايضا في احد
اوروبا احنا بخليك تستمتع وكمان ايضا
تتجهز لمباريات المونديال المباراه
القادمه الساعه 7:00 شكرا جزيلا لكم
الماسك ومفيد العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
اعتمد ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان نتوجه التنموي لجزيره دارين وتروت
كما وافق ايضا على انشاء مؤسسه لتطوير
جزيره دارين وتاروت بميزانيه تقديريه بلغت
نحو مليارين و600 مليون ريال وتمتد
الجزيره السعوديه على مساحه 32 كيلو متر
مربعا ويقطنها 120,000 سنه
علينا هاتفيين الامير احمد بن فهد نائب
وامير منطقه الشرقيه نائب رئيس مجلس
الاداره ورئيس اللجنه التنفيذيه لهيئه
تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه اسمه الامير مرحبا
بك معي في النشره الرابعه من الرياض بدايه
كيف تقراون هذا
الاعتماد لتوجه التنموي لجزيره دارين
وتاروت من ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد الامير حفظه الله العظيم الشكر
والامتنان اا ما بيشكرين القرار الكريم
باعتماد التوجه التنوي للجزيره
ولي العهد سوف ينعكس بشكل ايجابي ان شاء
الله على الجانب الاقتصاد المنطقه وهو
يعكس بشكل
سيدي ولي العهد حفظه الله على التنميه
الشامله بحيث تشمل كل مدينه في المملكه
مع التركيز على الاستفاده من المميزات
النسبيه لكل منطقه والعمل بشكل استراتيجي
منظم لاستقرار وتحفيظ الاستثمار ورفع جوده
الحياه همم السكان ومواطنين المملكه
وهذا واضح الحقيقه من قارات انشاء الهيئات
التنمويه مثل هيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه
والتطوير منطقه الهيئه تطوير الاحساء
والحقيقه انه ما نشاهده اليوم في واحده من
مبادرات الاستراتيجيه التي عملت عليها
هيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه
وتم التركيز فيه على ثلاث محاور رئيسيه
اولها المحافظه على الجانب الثقافي
والتراثي للمكان اضافه الى حمايه والتفعيل
المواقع الطبيعيه والبيئيه وبلا شاكل
المحور الثالث والتفعيل دور الجزيره في
تعزيز الاقتصاد السياحي والاصدقائي بجوده
الحياه
والحمد لله خلال السنتين ماضيه كان العمل
مستمر عن التهاب المساحات والدراسات
البيئيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وغيرها
الهيئه باذن الله تكمل العمل مع الشركاءات
المختلفه القطاعات على هذه المباراه
استراتيجيه يضاف الى مبادرات اخرى باذن
الله
سمو الامير حتى اقرار هذا الاعتماد لكن
خليني اسال ايضا عن الى اي درجه يمكن ان
تسهم طبعا هذه المؤسسه مؤسسه تطوير جزيره
دارين وتاروت في انها تطور تغير تحدد ايضا
في هذه الجزيره جزيره دارين وتاروت
مؤسسه تطوير جزيره دارين تاروت مؤسسه غير
البحيره طبعا وهي خطوه غير مسبوقه في
تاريخ التنميه في المنطقه الشرقيه
والاجابه على سؤالك تم تخصيص مليارين و600
ااه
و 44 مليون ريال كجمال تكاليف الجزيره لان
سنه الله وثلاثين
ايضا سوف يتم نقل الانشطه الصناعيه خارج
جزيره دارين وتاروت وحصل على مصالح
الاهالي المنطقه والمستثمرين راح تتولى
امانه المنطقه الشرقيه هذا الملف بحسب
الاجراءات المتبعه بما يحفظ حقوق الناس
جميعا
وما بشكل المبادره تضمنت عدد مشاريع جديده
في قطاعات مختلفه واللي تتحقق باذن الله
الاف الوظائف لابناء المنطقه الشرقيه
وبالاخص اهالي جزيره هارون
اكثر من مره في اجاباتك علينا ان همم
الاثر الاقتصادي
لتاسيس هذه المؤسسه المؤسسه التطويب دارين
جزيره دارين وتاروت كيف يمكن الحديث عنها
سمو الامير بشكل
والله الحقيقه الدراسات العملات تشيرن
المبادره سوف تتحقق باذن الله اجر اقتصادي
واجتماعي كبير في مساهمه هذه المبادره في
الناتج الاجمالي المحلي حسب الدراسه
ستكون
يصل الى
2077 مليون ريال سنويا مع تقديرات متوقعه
يعني الوظائف باذن الله اكثر من 100,000
همم فرصه عمل في الجانب السياحي اللي هو
ايضا مهم جدا همم متوقع ان يصل اجمالي
الزوار والسائحين للجزيره الى مليون
و300,000 سائح بحلول 20 30 ان شاء الله
وان شاء الله بتشهد المنطقه الشرقيه بحول
الله عدد المبادرات والمشاريع النوعيه من
خلال هيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه وهي
تطوير الاحزاب والشراسه مع جهاد اخرى من
قطاعين العام والخاص
الاقتصادي كبير وارقام مبهره ايضا سمو
الامير انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر
لانضمامك الينا كان مع الهاتفيا الامير
احمد بن فهد نائب وامير المنطقه الشرقيه
نائب رئيس مجلس الاداره ورئيس اللجنه
التنفيذيه لهيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه
اعلنت هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه عن ارتفاع
الصادرات السلعيه غير البتروليه بنسبه
تتجاوز 13 في المئه بنهايه الربع الثالث
من العام الجاري وبالمجمل بلغت قيمته
صادرات السعوديه نحو 400 مليار ريال ريال
اكثرها في المنتجات المعدنيه هيئه الاحصاء
اوضحت ايضا حجم التجاره السعوديه التي
تجاوزت 580 مليار بين صادرات وواردات من
دول عده ابرزها الصين وكوريا الجنوبيه
وامريكا
في السعوديه ايضا افتتحت شركه سابك مبناها
الاداري والذي حصل على شهاده مبنى ليد
الذهبيه للبناء المستدام في اداره الموارد
وكفاءه الطاقه وتبلغ مساحه البناء
الاجماليه للمبنى اكثر من 250.000 متر
مربع بمساحه استيعابيه تتسع لاكثر من
ثلاثه الاف 1600 موظف الشركه السعوديه
اعتمدت على المحتوى المحلي بنسبه 77% في
مشتريات المبنى الرئيسي والتي شملت
الاعمال الميكانيكيه والكهربائيه واعمال
التشطيب تشنا شركه سابك مجامعه الاداريه
في المركز الاقتصادي بمدينه الجبال
الصناعيه وهو احدث مشاريع العملاقه في
المدينه يمثل المبنى منصه حيويه لزياده
قدره سابق لتعزيز حضورها المؤثر في صناعه
البتروكيماويات عالميه
[موسيقى]
مجمع وسابك الاداري ايقونه معماريه تشكل
باكوره المشاريع العملاقه في المركز
الاقتصادي بمدينه الجبيل الصناعيه محقق
المستشفيات السابقه في توفير افضل الاجواء
البيئيه الملائمه وتلبيه متطلباتها
الانتاجيه وتوسعات اعمالها
[موسيقى]
28 طابقا وتشكل مساحه المبنى
245000 متر مربع وتبلغ مساحه الارض
66000 متر مربع يضمه مباني اداريه ومركزه
بيانات عالمي ومركز التعلم والتطوير اضافه
الى وسائل لرفاهيه ومرافقه متعدده كما
انها سبعه 77% من المواد والخدمات
المستخدمه في هذا المجمع هي من السوق
المحلي وقد زود المجمع في نحو
321,000 نظام ميكانيكي وتقني وامني
وكهربائي واكثر من 2500 لوحه شمسيه تستخدم
لتوليد الطاقه النظيفه
[موسيقى]
انجازاته يحققها مجمع سابك الاداري منها
حصوله على شهاده نيوتن العالميه لجوده
مراكز المعلومات وشهاده اليد الذهبيه
للمباني الصديقه للبيئه كما يهيئ المجمع
التحول نحو التوسع في اعمال سابق
وشراكاتها وتعزيز خططتها لنمو ورفع كفاه
الاداء كما يساهم في جعل مدينه الجبيل
الصناعيه
فرص الاستثمار والخدمات اللوجسيه
[موسيقى]
من الجبيل الصناعيه علي اللغبي العربيه
الموارد البشريه السعوديه توقف اربعه
شركات استخداما بسبب مخالفاتها الانظمه
واللواء
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد وقفت وزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه في السعوديه
سته شركات عامله في مجال الموارد البشريه
والاستقدام لمخالفتهم قواعد ممارسه
الاستقدام وتقديم الخدمات العماليه ضمن
جهود الوزاره في الاعمال الرقبه في
السعوديه
اطلقت الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلا
مهرجان الممالك القديمه والذي يتضمن تجارب
ثقافيه تاريخيه متنوعه تعود الى الاف
السنين ونظمه الهيئه
للزوار والسياح رحله تبرز هويتك كل موقع
وتاريخ بدا من عروض الضوء واصولا الى رحله
المنطاد وكذلك الجوله عبر الطائرات
المروحيه في مختلف المواقع التراثيه
من محافظه خيبر شمال غرب السعوديه ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه نصفين هاني مساء
الخير مرحبا بكم
من الرياض تجارب ثقافيه تاريخيه متنوعه
ايضا في هذه المنطقه منطقه خيبر كيف تبدو
وما الذي رصدته حتى اليوم
نعم اهلا بك نايف واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اذا المحافظه خيبر من المحافظات
السياحيه الجديده التي تسعى الهي الملكيه
للعلا ان تكون منطقه جذابه خاصه ان هذه
المحافظه تحديدا تحتوي على الف تاريخي
وحضاري وكذلك معالم كثيره سواء على
المستوى تاريخي او الجيولوجي او ايضا
اليوم هو سياحي عموما بينما الكاميرا
العربيه تتجول سوف يكون معي الاستاذ احمد
الامام وهو مدير المحتوى هنا في المحافظه
او الهيئه الملكيه للعلا لليوم استاذ احمد
يعني خيبر دخلت ضمن السياحي الجديد للهيئه
كيف يعملون اليوم لجذب السياح لهذه
المنطقه التاريخيه الحضاريه همم طبعا
محافظه خيبر كما تعلم همم عنصر اساسي في
همم مهرجان الممالك القديمه في الهيئه
الملكيه لمحافظه العلا ونحن اليوم همم هنا
نتوج ثالث الثالوث المميز من الثلاث واحات
واحد تيما وواحد العلا وواحد خيبر همم
واحد خيبر تعتبر مميزه بعناصر جماليه
كثيره لا نستطيع ان نحصيها او همم نتعامل
معها همم
الا بمراحل فبدانا هذه المرحله الاولى
وهذا الموسم الاول ان شاء الله سوف يستمتع
الزائر
بمعلومات عن الطبيعه وعن الاثار والارث
الموجود في محافظه خيبر بعد الطرق وعده
اشكال نحن الان قبل ما تغادر الكاميرا في
مركز همم خدمه العلماء
في معرفه السياح لو نتحدث عن هذا المركز
وكيف يتم تعرف السياح على معالم محافظه
خيبر طبعا ما يميز خيبر هو التنوع في
انماط السياحه الجيولوجيه الطبيعيه
والثقافيه والتراثيه لذلك ايضا حاولنا ان
نوصل للمعلومه الى الزائرين من كل انحاء
العالم ااا بعده اشكال وعده الطرق يستطيع
الزائر ان ااه يتعرف على محافظه خيبر من
خلال الصور الموجوده من خلال الشاشات
التفاعليه والافلام الوثائقيه المعروضه في
مركز زوار ايضا المحتوى الصوتي او المرشد
الصوتي يستطيع الزائر انه يتعرف على خيبر
ويتجول بالمحتوى الصوتي وايضا من محبي
السياحه التقليديه والمرشد السياحي
التقليدي ايضا يستطيع ان يجد مرشد سياحي
يتحدثون بعده لغات الانجليزيه والعربيه
والاسبانيه والفرنسيه سواء الاخير بشكل
سريع نحن في منطقه اسمها منطقه الروان وهي
احدى المناطق التي تم تهيئتها هنا في
محافظه خيبر كي تكون منطقه جذابه سياحيه
لو نتحدث عنها بشكل سريع نعم قريه الروان
من اجمل القراء كما تتحدث انه في كثير من
العناصر الجماليه وكثير من القران لكن
واحه الروان وقريه الروان يعني بدايه
مميزه نستطيع ان نقول تكون ان شاء الله
بدايه تجربتنا مع الزوار من كل انحاء
العالم نستقبل فيها الزوار ثم بعد ذلك
نستطيع في المواسم القادمه نتوسع بعد
الروان
والعيون الموجوده طبعا في الواحه من اميز
العيون الموجوده في محافظه خيبر لذلك
عندما نتوسع الان نعرف همم ماذا يرغب
الزائر ماذا يج- يريد ان يشاهد ومن خلاله
نستطيع ان نتوسع في المراحل القادمه
استاذ احمد الامام مدير المحتوى هنا في
الهيئه الملكيه للعليا كان يتحدث لنا عن
محافظه خيبر وعن هذه المنطقه منطقه الروان
التي شاهدناها والتقطتها الكاميرا العربيه
والتي سوف يكون او سوف تكون منطقه لجذب
السياح ايضا من الخارج كما تحدث الاستاذ
احمد وهي منطقه من وجهه السياحيه الجديده
بالنسبه لي السعوديه لمحافظه او ل هي
الملكيه العلماء اشكرك شكرا جزيل انت
وضيفك الكريم والمحافظه السعوديه ضمه
الينا مراسل العربيه
هاني صغير من الرابع
279 ملي متر من الامطار على محافظه جده
خلال 6 ساعات
الارصاد تصدر تحذيرا هطول امطار غزيره على
السواحل الغربيه وتحذر من السيول المنقوله
غير النفطيه السعوديه تسجل ارتفاعا باكثر
من 13% خلال ثلاثه اشهر
سويسرا تتغلب على الكاميرون
والبرازيل تواجه يصير بها مساء اليوم
مباريات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]